we come together
today
before all that we hold sacred
and all that makes us truly human
and we ask
for a blessing
may we untie
the deep knots of racism
may we unfurl
a new banner
of freedom
may we speak the truth so boldly that we
shake the seats of power
may we listen
so bravely
that our own hearts are shaken free
may we find strength in community as we
break bread together
and as we go forth from this place
may we take hold of the precious strands
of history that are our own lives
so that together
we may bend the ark of our time
closer and closer
to the great dream of justice
amen
thank you for the blessing
thank you all for coming today i hope
you've enjoyed this morning's program it
has been a wonderful event which i hope
has inspired you not only to remember dr
king's words but to act upon them
now we invite you to stay for the
delicious lunch
you